♪ It's the heart ♪
♪ Afraid of breaking ♪
♪ That never ♪
♪ learns to dance ♪
- James isn't even speaking to me.
- Don't worry about James,
James is a cunt.
♪ Afraid of waking ♪
♪ That never ♪
♪ takes the chance ♪
♪ It's the ones ♪
♪ Who won't be taken ♪
♪ Who can not seem to give ♪
♪ And the soul ♪
♪ Afraid of dying ♪
♪ That never ♪
♪ Learns to live ♪
(audience clapping)
- Lovely altogether.
You know, every year,
I sit backstage listening to the singers,
and it really makes me realize
just how talented the professionals
who originally recorded these tracks were.
Now, who's on next?
(Irish music)
(audience clapping)
Christ, this is penance.
I'm not doing it again,
I mean it this time.
Up next we have
Orla McCool.
- Christ.
(pop music)
♪ When the time grew near ♪
♪ For me to show my love ♪
♪ The longer I stayed away for ♪
♪ Hiding from a word I need to hear now ♪
(laughter)
♪ Don't think I'll hear it again ♪
♪ But the nights were
always warm with you ♪
♪ Holding you right by my side ♪
(audience laughing)
♪ Right by my side ♪
♪ But the morning always comes too soon ♪
♪ Before I even close my eyes ♪
(audience laughing)
♪ All I do each night is pray ♪
♪ Hoping that I'll be a
part of you again someday ♪
(audience laughing)
♪ All I do each night is think ♪
- What's wrong with Orla?
- She's such a dick.
(audience laughing)
- Yeah, she might be a dick.
But she's my dick.
- Actually, she's our dick.
♪ And all of the days and the nights ♪
♪ Oh I'll regret it ♪
♪ I never showed you my love ♪
- Oh for fuck's sake.
♪ Holding you right by my side ♪
♪ Right by my side ♪
♪ But the morning always comes too soon ♪
♪ Before I even close my eyes ♪
- [TV Narrator] In what
has already been described
as one of the worst atrocities
of the Northern Irish conflict,
at least 12 people are thought to be dead,
and many more wounded.
Emergency services are urging
anyone with medical training
to come to the scene immediately.
The device was detonated at
3:00 p.m. this afternoon.
(pop music)
The RUC says no warning was given.
♪ Oh my life ♪
♪ Is changing everyday ♪
♪ In every possible way ♪
♪ And oh my dreams ♪
♪ It's never quite as it seems ♪
♪ Never quite as it seems ♪
♪ I know I've felt like this before ♪
♪ But now I'm feeling it even more ♪
♪ Because it came from you ♪